At the tip of Africa, where it was unthinkable to deliver products...
...that's at the level of Paris and Tokyo and New York,...
...we're now in a position where we're actually delivering at training local people...
...at levels that you expect in Paris.
And a couple of weeks ago,...
...we were recognized as one of the four best croissant producers in the world,...
...and by default, bakery.
I had a lot of croissants in different places.
I must say, this croissant is the perfect butter croissant...
...because it is quite important if you bite into the croissant,...
...it needs to make the sound and it needs to have this buttery...
...and yeah, obviously, Paris kind of style, flavor.
I can't even explain it, but it is like the croissant you would expect in Paris.